ABC in Houston has a report about an
interesting case in their City uh let's
watch let's watch the
report Harry Evans walks into the
Carter's Country gun store on June 21st
2022 during the day goes straight for
the cash register opens the drawer and
appears to be taking something out of it
when a male and female employee appear
the man Winger starts firing at Evans as
he runs into the parking lot an autopsy
showed he was hit twice and died prior
to entering Carter's Country Houston
Police say Evans had gone into a
neighboring clothing store attempted to
steal and got into a fight with
employees within the last week Winger
was indicted by a grand jury on a murder
charge attorney Steve shst is not
related to the case but he says he does
not see that the shooter has much of a
defense I don't pretend to know what was
going on in the shooter's mind at the
time I'm sure he thought he was doing
the right thing by protecting the store
in protecting the property but
unfortunately it was outside the the
bounds of the
law so this to me is uh a total
miscarriage of justice and I say that
while acknowledging that by the letter
of the law technically uh the guy's
probably guilty well you just heard
there about the letter of the law is is
true
but the law is wrong and anyway we also
know that you know people who are
definitely guilty of all kinds of crimes
are let off the hook all the time
prosecutors say either slap on the wrist
or they just don't prosecute or whatever
so we know that happens all the time
prosecutors should do the same thing
here uh they're not doing it because
they're more interested in uh going
after guys like this than going after
actual Perpetual criminals like the guy
that was killed here because the fact is
that a person and and I'm talking I'm
not talking about the letter of the law
I'm talking about just what is actually
right and what is morally
right um a person should have the right
to defend their property and their
business with whatever means they deem
necessary it would be very good to live
in a society where criminals are afraid
to steal because they know they might be
killed that would be a good thing you
know if you have criminals who uh are on
the verge of potentially committing a
crime like this and they stop themselves
they say I don't know I I don't want to
get shot and killed that's a good thing
that is a sign of a healthy and
well-ordered Society it's how it should
be don't want to get shot don't steal
that's all it's not complicated it's not
a complicated thing that's why there's
no there's no Injustice to my mind
there's Injustice in how this uh
employee is being treated but but in his
response shooting the other guy that's
not
unjust you know he he didn't go find
this guy while he was like sitting down
for lunch somewhere and kill
him the guy came in decided to steal
just don't if you didn't do that you
wouldn't get shot simple
equation and if you steal you deserve
whatever happens as a result you know
there people will say well he stole he
doesn't deserve to die over that yeah he
does he actually
does you made that decision you have no
right to do that you have no right to do
you have no right to just walk into a
store and take from the cash register
you don't have any right to do that and
you're doing something you have no right
to do and so your own rights have been
suspended in that moment I mean you have
forfeited your own
rights by doing something you have no
right to
do and whatever happens as a result you
deserve you do deserve
it uh and this should be the logic of
the justice
system you know the just system should
say oh you got shot what were you doing
when you got shot were you sitting uh at
at your house were you taking a nap were
you just walking down the street
innocently were you volunteering at a
soup kitchen were you visiting an
elderly uh woman at a nursing home oh oh
no you weren't oh you were stealing you
were stealing from a gun store you
okay well that's your problem we
don't care your
fault oh you're dead well sorry sorry
about your luck sorry you decided to
throw your life away like that you
idiot I mean this is what the system
should
say that would be
Justice and it's not just because a
person who steals deserves whatever
happens as a result they
do but that's not just the point it's
also that citizens should be able to
protect their
livelihood um defending your property
your livelihood that that is Defending
Your Life it is
self-defense because our lives depend on
uh our jobs they depend on
what we own so when people say oh it's
just property it's just money what do
you mean just property just money what
are you talking about your life depends
on
that your life depends on your property
it depends on your
money if you don't have any property or
any money then then you're you you are
very vulnerable to all kinds of things
so your life depends on it and you
should have the right to defend your
property and the person stealing it as
far as I'm concerned has no right
that's the way it should work and you
shouldn't have to justify it it's not
it's it's it shouldn't be up to anyone
else to come in Monday Morning
Quarterback and after the cas after the
fact and say well you didn't technically
need that property you could have been
fine without it who you de say could
have been fine without it it's not your
property it's not your decision to make
I don't care what your opinion
is this is mine it's it's mine it's not
yours don't take it don't want to get
shot don't take
it so
what I always ask in these situations is
what is the slippery slope in either
direction okay I mean if you think about
it what if let's just say in my fantasy
scenario um which I know is not the
country we live in but but I think it is
it should be so so what if we were to
Grant basically total leeway to the
victims of robberies and thefts and what
if we were to say hey if someone steals
from you then through the whole Act of
stealing even while they're running away
you have the right to do whatever you
need to do to recover your property okay
now I'm not saying that if someone tries
to steal from you and you recover your
property and then they run away that you
know you can hunt them down the next day
in an act of Vengeance and just kill
them while they're sitting on their
front
porch um that obviously would not be
okay because that's but but through the
whole Act of
stealing you you doesn't yeah doesn't
the whole act whether they're coming
after you or they're not whether they
have a gun or they don't through the
whole Act of stealing you have the right
just do whatever you need to do to get
your property back that person is doing
something they have no right to do
they've forfeited their own rights in
the process they've made that decision
it's completely on them it's not anyone
else's fault but theirs and so do what
you need to do to get your property back
and if you do that you know we're we're
going to we're going to look the other
way uh we're going to you know we're
going to do everything in our power to
um be as lenient on you as possible what
if we were to say that as a
society what's the slippery
slope like what ends up happening you
know how does that harm
us worst case we end up with a lot of
dead thieves and there are many people
who would say I don't know if that's
really a worst case but that is the wor
however you look at it that's the worst
case you end up with a lot of dead
thieves um really best case scenario is
you don't end up with a lot of dead
thieves I mean I don't want to see
people dead no matter one way or another
I'd prefer if if if nobody was shot um
I'd love to live in a world where that
was it's never necessary to shoot
anybody that's what I would prefer to
live in a Utopia we don't but um best
case to me so worst case a lot of dead
thieves best case is that you don't end
up with a lot of dead thieves and
robbers because people decide not to do
that in the first place knowing that
their own life is at risk and knowing
that if they do this
the justice system will be entirely on
the victim's side and so they're going
to be screwed because either they're
going to get shot and killed in the
process or they're going to have or
they're going to survive and they're
going to get the book thrown at them uh
by the justice system while they're when
they're prosecuted for being a thief
Grand can University is an affordable
private Christian University based in
Phoenix Arizona they're dedicated to
making education fit into your already
busy schedule which is why they offer
270 of their academic programs online
from scholarship to academic support
gcu's graduation team provides you with
the personal support you need to obtain
your goals gcu's online programs offer
you the freedom to earn your degree on
your own time from wherever you are GCU
is praised for its culture of community
giving an impact they integrate the free
market system and a welcoming Christian
worldview into all of their academic
programs achieve your goals with a
personalized plan and a supportive team
behind you find your purpose at Grand
can University private Christian
affordable visit gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
so that's you know that's the that's the
slippery
slope oh no how
terrible on the other hand if you
grant more rights to the thieves than to
the
victims if you make people too afraid to
defend themselves and their
property
um then we don't need to speculate about
the consequences because we're living
those consequences right now
we all know what
happens right we we know what the
slippery slope scenario is in that
case we're we're we're living it then
then you have just the breakdown of
public order you have the breakdown of
Law and Order you have the breakdown of
society you have you have uh cities that
are
unlivable you have one Community after
another that becomes
unlivable and we're law-abiding people
who
just all they want to do is they want to
open up a business they want to work at
a you know they want to get a job they
want to open a business they want to be
contributing members of
society uh where you you end up in a
situation where those people
are uh made to live in fear or you're
chasing them out of the community to
begin
with you end up in a world where the the
the leeches the
parasites the people have no interest in
being contributing members of society at
all where those people are more
empowered than the people who are trying
to follow the law and trying to
contribute to society and take care of
themselves and their
families so that's a slippery slope in
the other direction and we're living it
we know how it
goes and uh and it's it's not good to
say the least if You' like to see what
else I have to say you can access my
full show by going to dailywire.com or
by going to the Matt wall Show Twitter
page hope to see you there godp speed